The city should be a space of coexistence where you have everything
at hand, like a city of 15 minutes.
We made our own project for Pontevedra,
which was a city that at that time
had 73,000 inhabitants.
Now we have 84,000
throughout the whole municipality,
mostly in the center of the city,
which used to be uninhabitable.
It was polluted with cars, really noisy,
contaminated,
and people had no autonomy
to occupy any public space.
For that, we did a few things:
eliminate unnecessary traffic
so that the city works.
Second is crosstown traffic.
We had a study that said that 30%
of the cars that cross the city
did not stop in the city.
Then we had the so-called
agitation traffic,
which resulted from all
those cars circling around
until a parking spot opened up.
We went from 30%
dedicated to public space in the city
and 70% dedicated to motor traffic
to the inverse, 70% for the people
and 30% for the traffic
necessary for the city to function.
What happened?
This led to less pollution,
less noise, less traffic jams,
which after 24 years we
have shown are very few,
and are perfectly compatible
with high quality of life
and above all with great economic activity,
and it makes the city more attractive.
The people have won.
It was the space that was freed from
cars and improved and illuminated
and filled with activities, etc.
It was filled with people.
Since 2011, we haven’t had a single
death from a hit-and-run in the city.
This street used to have back-in parking, parallel parking,
sidewalks narrowed to one meter,
and cars double-parked and triple-parked.
This street was absolutely unlivable
and what we transformed it into is a space
with a single platform for hanging out,
and it really improved a lot in every sense.
I know many people who come to live in Pontevedra because they have children
and prefer a city with this quality
of life over living in another city,
especially people who
can afford to telework.
There are even many foreigners,
Americans, English, French,
that live here and work, and choose Pontevedra for its quality of life.
When we talk about
recovering public space,
we are talking about democracy,
we are talking about equality,
we are talking about rights,
we are talking about making
a feminist design of public space,
because women are the ones
who use that space the most.
We have to fight for quality of life,
to avoid climate change, to improve
the autonomy of people,
to create democracy in the public space,
for social cohesion, for all of that.
Can there be opposition?
I’m not saying there can’t be,
but citizens are smarter
than some politicians think and
they understand perfectly
when you are acting in favor
of the general interest
or you are defending particular and private interests that are usually the same.
I think that it is mainly because
people are reluctant
to change and afraid of
what they might lose.
When you leave your house,
you need to find a public space that
is continuous with your own house,
that is calm, that is safe,
that is pleasant, that is attractive,
and that has an urban design
that can be easily read.